welcome to this video this is courage
for round three of the Tata Steel
tournament in my ganze the Netherlands
and I need to tell you something right
away this will be a problematic video
the thing is I worked all day and I only
got to really work on this close to
midnight and wow I mean it's great for
the spectator but bad for the
commentator I was going to do a video on
it all games today had some interesting
points or were plain really great so wow
I really don't know what to do I
couldn't really figure out that much
about the games some of them were so
complicated I really had no idea what's
going on and even even if you really
extensively use a computer it won't yeah
get you that that close to something
something true about the games okay i
will just do what I can with that what's
with those games I hope you enjoy the
coverage it will definitely be well not
perfect in some cases i will probably
overlook stuff or things but you'll get
an impression what happened I'm for sure
lets them get going I'm starting with
the game ding Liren against barrage
abhava yeah um they both will dingers on
fifty percent he lost against Cara wanna
but scored a win against who you fall
and your Baba really has a bad
tournament yeah he lost the first round
is somewhat yeah let's say stupid loss
against even shook and it didn't really
go that well he played the drawing round
two pretty uneventful draw let's see
what happened today I got somewhat
uncommon opening yeah Bishop f5 here
this is a rare line of the old Indian
with d6 this is not that bad but it's
fairly uncommon Knight c3 and now black
played the move age 6 at
looks can you weird you've probably
would expect something like 97 or g6 but
I've sticks is possible give some square
for the bishop this has been played by
some good players it's not totally am
totally stupid the general idea is 97 85
later and then Bishop e7 and so on this
is just trying to control reform yeah
thing is going with g3s I think a good a
good setup he wants to put something on
g2 of the bishop to ultimately control e
for a good idea and like you know when
c6 know that that kind of fits into the
general setup you know d5 was played
yeah and this is a think a good move the
ideas maybe 94 which would attack the
bishop and to take on c6 so c 6 i'm
clicking out that square no no it
actually takes the click yeah this is
the weakness now and if black does not
react to that like why let's say he does
that then this will be really really
awkward will lose material structure
what not this is even material loss so
he has to react to it and blade c5 and
now we have a very very strange form of
benoni yeah we're white castle where
somehow nothing's really well positioned
if you play g6 in this structure this
Bishop does not have any squares to go
to well no decent graph G for but easily
a tree as possible you know to
illustrate the point let's say he does
that something like this we lose the
bishop it's a very stupid line but it
might happen yeah this kind of thing so
black needs to take care of it and he
does so by radical means he plays g5 and
when I first saw this I was thinking
well this is a fun joke it really looks
like a terrible move yeah weakening
everything and what what exactly am are
you doing here where are you going to
put your King now and especially
considering that white has aged 4
immediately this was played G 491 yeah
as mentioned i first thought this is
totally ridiculous to be
this g5 stuff but if you look at it a
little bit longer and well I didn't as i
mentioned didn't have ages of time but
if you look at it the longer it has some
points if black now goes 95 which he
didn't and i think this was was a big
mistake if he does that now quickly
trying to do this kind of setup this
night only five is actually quite nicely
placed it cannot so easily be kicked
away with f4 yeah as then you take on
pasong yeah i mean just this is this is
what i'm talking about making some sense
of the jeep or so probably 95 was quite
ok Ferb like that some it's nothing
special for wide maybe I still fi doubts
about the concept but well he went
Bishop g7 and now we form bishop had to
draw back 111 idea of g5 was this move
that you can go back to 87 and now night
here to d3 and now we see the big issue
black it's not managing night 25 anymore
and if you don't get this in how do you
coordinate your position a very tricky
thing um he went a 6 a-4 quince is seven
Bishop e3 this is what happened and the
big problem is well I don't really see
what black should do if he cancelled
short his king will be in trouble I mean
this is really not a great configure
configuration in front of your king but
at least he's got some some some pieces
near it the other problem is that you're
also in bad shape on the Queen sodium
something like a 5 + B form is coming at
at at later stage in those bishops they
don't do much this is fairly often for
black fairly awful to Baba plate also
really quickly this is I didn't know
that that kind of can weird yeah I know
maybe he's frustrated or anything well
this is well what he did now is
canceling long after that white is
winning simply I mean this is like
computers winning white cannot cannot
allow a draw from this position because
well he's attacking on the queenside
and with the king over them this is just
very very nice for white yeah and he
went rook b1 intending to play before
it's not rocket science black also
cannot play a five year as I guess night
b5 and attack against the e5 pawn will
be a problem I mean other than that I me
can also play before I to open up the
position it is terrible maybe this was
still a little bit more tenacious I
don't know 95 still looks terrible Queen
here so maybe bishop okay well II for
hang so I don't know maybe 95 is a
little bit too quick wit he where he
went it went ecigs still playing
instantly after which before hit and
well I don't see how you save this
simply far far too much on the king
betta xe5 that's of course a strong move
yeah we opening up the position as much
as possible and if black adjust
reCAPTCHA cm and what gets the bishop to
f4 terrible queen hair 95 threatening 97
checkmate yeah and in such a position I
mean the thing is this is opening up and
white has all pieces in the attack
Bishop Bishop the pawns the rook the
night everything and black has those
kind of useless pieces it's a win this
is a win yeah this is what happened 'if
I've yeah fleshy move it wasn't
necessary you also could have taken on
d6 the ideas if black takes this will
take here we'd be eight and we are
breaking through
only here did do bhava take like 15
minutes it's a really weird way to play
okay well 95 I mean Iggy I don't know
hey I really don't know what to say this
is like a complete slaughter this game
why does just attacking with all pieces
and like is in disarray 23 and queen
before I could be two he resigned yeah
if black takes them the piece here for
example then can be six hits and it's
made somewhere it all this let's move
can you take here for Queen B seven I
mean when you have a position where all
your pieces are attacking well it's very
often just check mate and this is the
KCM a really weird game by gee bajwa I
really don't know what happened there
would be interesting to him to hear the
press conference I didn't I didn't I
didn't I couldn't do any of that I'd
have no information because it's really
weird you blitz out those stuff which is
I mean to call it strategically risky is
really an understatement you blitz all
that stuff and then all of a sudden when
the guy plays the totally obvious moves
you start to think I mean not quite sure
what he expected retakes c5 is nice of
course but and I mean even if white is
not doing that he has a fantastic
position you're not going to survive
that even if I just play some something
something simple I don't don't think
that this is this is this is player
really but okay let's um go to the next
game yvonne chaka vane Valley is the
next game that I'm going to look at
there's really no big sorting idea
behind it there of all interesting all
games played today could have ended with
a win I think there may be maybe one
game there was no clear for one side but
it was a very fighting game so
spectacular round even shook he goes
with efore again and here
the second to open Sicilian just as he
had in round 1 u 1 shook plays all
openings and yeah we know when is sort
of while everything's going for him he
can beat anybody on any given name and
we will see what he does in this game
against van Valen Queenie to a 6 and
long castles yeah Queenie two fields a
bit weird but it seems to be a valid
line it's not very popular but it's
quite interesting what why did is he
quickly got in long castles and the
Queen only two definitely has this
important function to cover g4 so that
with the Queen and II to you very often
have to play f3 to prevent 94 why would
the Queen here you prevented just by by
the Queen ur looking at g4 and not a not
a bad setup and now after Bishop to d7
he went f4 so typical Sicilian stuff
rook c8 king be one yeah here this game
is actually something where I didn't
analyze that much I know that black was
in trouble pretty quickly but I'm not
quite sure where the way it started
where the problems begin well Queen c7
all this looks like send that stuff in
the society 5g form yeah well what you
what you can say is that those kind of
very very sharp lines where white is
allowed to cancel long and you can push
g4 f4 and so on some of those lines are
really out of fashion nowadays
especially if you talk about setups
where the bishop is coming to d7 like
some lines of the rouser and so on the
black is under some pressure and maybe
this is simply not that that great a way
to to play this dis opening the Sicilian
ah I don't know and what I do know is if
you look at the position just just now
down the road he went before yeah night
a4 and now we played a five maybe if I
is a problem I mean after that it's very
very forced and maybe well good for
white yeah probably five is not not
really on yeah even shook now plated
them in a very very yeah inspired way he
played g5 now attacking this night and
well the thing is now everything is
going to be forced you can absolutely
not play the night anywhere yeah you
cannot plane I GA this is this is
ridiculous you have white is jumping
right in night to d5 I mean night she
ate us is no move can quickly discard
that if you jump to g4 there's stuff
like this happening tempo and then let's
say Queen somewhere and what about h3
now that is strapped so the only thing
that black can play on on g5 is similar
to g4 which is what you played and it it
looks really not that clear yeah it's
it's a funny situation on the rock white
plate Queen 2g two black took the rock
and well this is a rook it's a complete
rook and now even shock doesn't even
bother with taking the knight on f6 he
just takes on a six wow so this is this
really made me pasa for a moment so why
does the rook down and he just takes the
time to take this porn on a six very
nice um but what exactly is it that
black you should play I really think
that I mean what I looked at and what
the computer is giving white is better
here so he maybe should have avoided the
c5 push the problem is all kinds of
things are hanging one piece a second
piece and they exchange and if three
things are hanging it's very difficult
to keep all of them normally not
possible yeah he went and with 97 which
is probably relatively speaking the best
move it's very difficult to play
something else I mean also consider if
you let's say
just put one move on if you if you move
the rook white will take here and has
this threat so you don't have the time
to even save this Bishop on you on
moving the the rook is completely out of
the picture and if you move the bishop
where would you go to maybe to age five
again this capture it comes with a
threat so wyd would win material he has
to do 97 yeah and well now even truck
just took the the bishop and he's an
exchange down from upon but he has all
the potential for great position the
rook is hanging and whoa look at the
position that is God Luke a 8 Bishop b5
wells and Bishop e7 and now n 5 yeah
this is nice yeah a huge space advantage
All Blacks pieces are sort of well there
they are pushed back and yeah this
doesn't look good Queen B 7 and now see
for keeping this this Bishop anchored
very nice move if black takes him right
recaptures until all of a sudden has
solved the issue of this slightly clumsy
night and here let's say after I don't
know castles or something what will play
something to the five at the right
moment maybe cover the bishop then go to
d5 or f6 is also also good in the game
he cancelled immediately not taking on
c3 which is I think a good decision but
now have six Jack f6 if you take and
track you're really shortening when
you're sort of suffering less yeah but
it's it's not a move you have to go back
and then luke t 6 yeah and this is
really falling apart now and this is in
fact leading to to really tragic comic
proportions the kind of position that
Blanco has he got a texture on d7 and he
couldn't even move the piece to a square
where it is not taken when g6
Bishop d7 was possible but Dwight has
all the time in the world black cannot
move any peace it's it's ridiculous in a
way age form and with age 5 and just
back with the Queen White has total
control Black has no move Bishop c7 and
do I just took them so we get this funny
situation of three minor pieces against
two rooks but White has two pawns in
addition and well look at those pieces
how they are positioned this is
fantastic yeah the night here covers d7
and those roofs they are completely
worthless amazing then white is now just
slowly crawling forwards taking this
pawn okay yeah now you got three passes
well isn't this isn't this an amazing
position how this is not a fun
experience for black and in fact after
96 ven ve decided to just resign the
game yeah amazing somewhere right out of
the opening there must be the problem
really I mean this I'm not an expert on
those lines this is really not my
territory but if you ask me I think this
is uncomfortable for black already if
you look at van veen each time you
already had spent tons of time iam Wally
von Schuch was playing rather rather
quickly yeah it was like I can also not
take here because of this mess more
images we come to this point yeah it
looked like an opening disaster in a way
black haired head have had problems
right of the bed and couldn't simply
couldn't couldn't hold the position the
next game now is Giri Kawana and have to
warn you that this is an exceedingly
long game and I'm not sure that I really
understand what's going on but I rather
be honest about it then until I tell you
some things that are not true
yeah they play a Queens gambit declined
kawana playing this very solid line
which is part of his repertoire he's
some very versatile it's playing the
goon felt which looks super aggressive
maybe on this level it's not but at
least it's a kind of an open position
that he's getting and he plays this very
conservative Queens gambit declined but
it's obviously a very good opening that
can be recommended to play on on all
levels really yeah 197 in the bishop f
49 hear the latest idea it's 94 and
kawana plays that something that Giro
Guerrier definitely could have expected
simply because this was played in the
recent game in the London classic
tournament between are not and Caruana
so this was some kind of clear that this
might come up the board Luke see one
takes takes this was the idea of 94
Blake wants to trade off one pay off
nights to get a little bit more room for
his pieces or that's wrong he wants to
trade pieces so that he has less pieces
crowning this little space that he has
nighty form also is interesting because
it invites this booth but if you look at
it that's not leading to anything
something like that yeah this is
something that black very much welcomes
he's opening up the position and if you
look at it black is somewhat ahead and
development he has castled already while
why does two moves away from castling
yeah well I think this is this is
probably how it should be played what
you idiot him but black is definitely
very solid in this position here Anand
played see takes be six by the way to
which kawana plate sorry I'm got this
wrong he played before before and after
a 5 a 3 they agreed relatively quick
draw but black does not seem to be in
any any huge danger one idea of this
whole operation of you look at this
structure is that you want to play
Bishop a6 at some point yep getting this
Bishop out and therefore solving the
eternal problem of the Queens gambit
declined you with this e 6 move there's
your box then Bishop if you solve that
problem you're normally totally okay in
the Queens gambit declined yeah well
this was played in the game today
gaining space and now a 3 to prevent
Bishop before an a5 to have the bishop
a6 option that's all very logical and
this is in fact a general virtue of the
Queens gambit declined and this is a
fairly logical opening everything's not
everything's but most things happen
based on very very sound classical
values and it's a good good opening to
explain to also somewhat weaker players
easier to explain than an opening like
the Benoni for example yeah black gets
rid of his bad piece and has a fairly
solid position and now after this we get
to an interesting moment here I think
that Kara wanna hear pretty I mean
without any big issues could have played
I don't know a normal move like like
look 28 or something and getting the
look away from possible a text this is
always an issue if there's unprotected
peas on a6 want to put it on a on a safe
square but he did something else you
played Bishop to d6 this is an
interesting move because it invites
complications and gary is going through
it he plays Knight to d7 an interesting
interesting decision yeah now koalas
intention is becoming clear he does not
want to play rook e8 and this is also
quite clear I am I mean you don't invite
and move like 97 to just play rupee ATM
then you also then you could have played
rook a eight in the first place young
and the point is he takes here and
offers the exchange interesting concept
definitely playable and geary took up
the challenge it took on a fade so what
was the whole idea of it this was the
idea
let us take only three desperado
desperado sequence the first thing to
notice that if white now captures here
this is really a mistake after Queen
well even Queen edge Shah has a move but
let's just look at the general structure
we don't need to look at concrete lines
this is a situation where black is
definitely more comfortable he has a
night for the rook but it's a fantastic
night only form and blacks play is much
easier what does not really have
anything to do with his rooks and black
can just stare well we can do all kinds
of things advancing slowly on the Kings
side trying to get to this is six pawn
well I'm not saying that he's much
better or anything but it's quite
uncomfortable for Wyatt you don't have a
constructive plan at all if black just
let's say once to draw in this position
he just sits there and does nothing yeah
and what will never ever ever go go
anywhere so this is not a good way to
win the exchange what gear we did is
better he just put the night back and
then after a bishop retreat we have a
different situation now the night Ronnie
form is not an eternal peace it can be
kicked away the right moon with f3 okay
this is not happening that that quickly
but we got Jen I to trade here and now I
have a different situation compared to
the line that i showed before with the
night only for now black has a bishop
instead of a night which is probably not
that great piece and the structure but
it has one very good post and we will
see that after and some moves yeah like
is switching it to the six you can ask
by the way why is white pushing all his
pawns well he doesn't really have any
other idea he has to open up the
position for the rooks and the only way
to do that is to push those pawns so I
think this was this was fine maybe you
can debate about the timing but in
general
is the right way to go and black
services exchange down but look at this
he's totally totally solid and
coordinated this is covered this those
those two things are protecting each
other the bishop is protecting the the
pawn the pollen is protecting the bishop
it's a perfectly sound structure for
black and will be very hard to break
down we come to some interesting moments
later mmm yeah I don't I mean they're
you could do commentary on those moves
but it's um it's really after limiting
some at some point and I have to get to
sleep also maybe I'm trying to get to
sleep before 3am here so why does
getting some way is opened up the age
far he has doubled on the edge file and
here's an interesting moment what about
the move Queen 2 h8 yeah not played by
Gary but he could have done that and
played this the bonus was attacked but
if you go here what about this end game
yeah end game because the Queen's will
be traded now I think it is just the
draw actually yeah this kind of thing I
don't think that white can win um one
big problem is that um you you're not
it's it's it's a matter of understanding
some concepts white will not win with
his rook alone yeah because the the
weaknesses here c 7 + f7 they are very
reliably protected you don't really
managed to set up a zoosk one or
something something great here with the
ruger loan it's a case where in order to
make any headway you need the king but
the king on the other hand is needed to
protect their for porn why do will
probably not be able to ever give up
there for porn as f four drops g5 right
after it and if Black gets those pawns
going he might play for a win so I mean
theoretically speaking if those pawns
were on light squares not
for what could do something like this
trying to somehow enter on the queenside
yeah like but f-for some breakthrough
yeah but how is this going to work there
is no way it is simply a draw okay white
kept kept the rogue on with Roxy three
they continued for really a long while
and so it gets interesting soon which
there was a missed something there was
one one interesting moment let me look
at it I got confused am here exactly
here on move 48 after King to g4 here
black has had a funny tactical idea that
would have led to yeah um probably to
equality straight away not easy to see
however if I've was possible funny
tactic that the computer points out
immediately of course the ideas that
after the capture black can take the
point is that this is even winning for
black this is a funny situation on Luke
and King and this is very difficult to
see ya this kind of that this and this
there is Queen before a very tricky
tactical motif the the best line after
you five is probably something like this
take stakes and then just move the rook
away but here black has gained from this
because the King now is really open
something like this is for example
threatening white ear has to be careful
to draw I mean he will but it is it is
not easy yeah but Givaudan do that he
played king sm as mentioned it's a very
easy move to miss and they continued for
a long while they traded f 746 but black
had just count to play with the Queen in
waiting and
and I only looked at this briefly and
couldn't really come to a conclusion if
there was any way for whites maybe
forward with this with this extra
exchange at some point maybe like f5 use
the jeep on it really seems that black
some ka against the king is guaranteeing
a draw that's very difficult for white
and they continued it for really for
ages they check it's a bit of a shame
maybe there was much more to it but I
cannot really can't really stay up all
night to do this they reach this end
game and I think this is a pretty
straightforward draw White has no one no
no a bigger dm2 to enter with with the
king they played this on for 25 more
moves and I think there is nothing to do
yeah Black has fortress type of position
he's even blocking the White King from
entering and he can whenever this pawn
is attacked he can always it can cover
it with the bishop from d45 I think it's
a draw they continued for a while it
check it's really a good indication if
QE didn't find anything then there is
nothing i guess i mean the comp is
always giving that plus one but yeah
it's not helping it's just to compute
the evaluation okay so in the next game
going to look at his some Vegeta graph
against a job off they actually played
the same line yeah the same line and one
c5 I really think that by the way if you
want the theoretical opinion here which
is maybe not totally up to date but my
my feeling always was that the only way
to test black in this night bd7
Lyonya of the Bishop f4 Queens gambit
declined the only way lc5 if this is
nothing for white the whole line is just
equal I mean why just tried other things
like a three or stuff like that when
black go see 5 and this is this kind of
this kind of position here is really
totally fine for black this is a pretty
solid isolated greenport position okay
c5 was played and here a job of went 9 h
5 that's the order move yeah compared to
the nightie for move the karana played
when what does not mean bad it's just
the more the more explored way too plain
yeah and in this game I have to admit
that they're only I've looked a little
bit at the later stages it was a fairly
standard position here the only
interesting moment comes now we're blue
5 was played and I'm not sure maybe this
was even unknown unknown theoretical
line I mean I mean maybe I have actually
a graph head and spend even a minute on
that yeah probably it's it's all known
c6 and I takes d5 is a funny move Dwight
could try but it's just leading to much
I didn't analyze that I just thought
about it also night XD hype the same
motif happened in a in a recent game
that i was watching live in one of my
league games league matches and maybe
rooks ehm try to unpin the special this
night something like this should be
should be fine yeah it's probably
probably okay for black yeah he went c6
now if you remember the world
championship match game game what's this
game free Ireland cards one hand one
there were similar motifs why does
getting some substantial pressure here
and now it's interesting decision we
Roxy one and he gives up two looks for
the Queen which is very often not a good
idea but here blacks coordination is
really not great yeah this rook is
really stupidly placed always in some
some discoveries in this f5 so this is
probably an interesting position for
wide to play route gate was played very
sensible and now f5 this was one way to
justify this thing rook c6 and age for
ya white so has some pressure and he
isn't this amazing he's got more time on
the clock then what he started to the
game with yeah this is some extreme
preparation a form and now it took like
20 minutes yeah after a four to play age
five yeah it's an interesting position I
really don't know what's going on to be
honest why does a bone down but he has
definite pressure what I do know is that
a couple of moves later here Bishop c5
Quincy form here again like is some upon
up that here he made a mistake and well
he has to do something like maybe like
groupie a door getting this a aid rook
in the game what he did is a mistake
technically inclined mistake deform this
is not good because of this Queen f3 or
Queenie forward what what was she like
growth plate this is very awkward now we
attack both rooks in a way it's kind of
a x-ray effect and well you have to play
a move that you really don't want to
play it to go back to ca it with this
room if you do this you're running into
a really big fork so he went back and
now 97 I don't know if you miss that how
to tell it's not that difficult to see
the move the problem is now that well
hanks and hangs and ooh what are you
playing yeah he really just blundered
into this position let's aim and I don't
know if blackberry is some
if he really can save himself now after
the c6 pawn is dropping note that
there's also an attack on the king
coming with with night and nine and
queen he way he played d3 and takes d2
very funny counter-attack but blacker
wants to I mean wants to it's not
enthusiastic about it but he has to get
to a position with Luke and Bishop
against the Queen and this is one way to
do it yeah and maybe here there's a
critical situation where she now played
Queen to d3 i'm curious how long it took
out that more played it instantly hmm
and it has a logic I'm not saying that
is any is a stupid move the computer
points out a funny funny impossibility
it wants to play night to c7 here which
looks weird but it it does make some
sense if you look at it it's very
similar but now you've got the rook on
g7 and white will get the pawn
definitely but under quite favorable
circumstances something like this is
what the computer is giving us the best
line will be too and here I think white
should win if we look at it compared to
the game yeah wyd went here takes takes
bishop here Queen here look back at
retakes and King now this is rook is
somewhat supporting this this pawn and
it's it's it's tricky it's really tricky
the Palmer come to a three maybe white
can still do something but this is the
kind of thing where you really need more
time to to to analyze it I mean wow I
don't know if he goes to a three what
did he do actually he played quince is
six
and it's very difficult to stop this
pawn the airport I mean white has a ton
of checks you can always draw but how
are you going to stop the point I mean
maybe you can just what did you do
actually gives check check check check
check they they they there they went to
the draw okay well wyd can try something
like that stopping this palmer this is a
winning attempt or is this in fact more
like losing a temp job we're losing is
difficult but yeah I you cannot really
try to win with the Queen iya black
probably can just shuffle with the king
if white now pushes his pawns is this
wait sorry I'm sorry I'm really stupid
here sorry like black and even
considered to push b5 can you do that I
Quincy too oh sorry check yo this is why
you have to go King edge it first you
have King edge 8 let's say f4 and then
be 5 e 6 before and this is the the
counter threat that probably keeps black
in the game g-form B 3 and B 3 Queen
takes a two
I have this funny move wow that's nice
Bishop takes the screen be a check we
need seven and wins yeah here here wide
Windsor getting this pawn Wow yeah there
was still some some interesting points
but they made a draw mean by perpetual
air probably the correct decision I'm
not blaming anyone here it was probably
the correct way to play okay so a draw
in this game but maybe why she could
have one someone with 97 very really
really difficult next one Zurich against
we fun sorry shower rich it's difficult
a German person in English pronunciation
a career pronouncing a Croatian name
it's difficult Zorich who you find so we
have a form and we get a Sicilian and
who you find this place playing g6
that's the hyper accelerated dragon yeah
the not even the accelerated the
hyperaccelerated dragon was not a g6 an
interesting line the idea is that you
want to you want basically what you want
you don't mind this thing that is the
accelerator dragon but you probably mind
that white can do this so if you want to
avoid it you start with this move
obviously Bishop g5 now is kind of
stupid so deform takes and now night x
96 transposase to what you want the only
drawback possibly is that white has
queen takes d4 hmm this is in fact what
Charlotte share plate and I always
thought that black should be okay in
this line but it is some this it's a
theoretical debate not a debate that is
on the let's say cutting edge of theory
but it's a something that is discussed
over the years how this position is to
be evaluated
yeah why does making tons of Queen moves
I know but he also establishes a very
strong pawn on e5 if black is not
fighting this pond quickly white will
establish this Bishop f4 93 long castles
and you don't know what to do against
this pawn the point is limiting your
Bishop on g7 can put it put on some
moves this part is limiting this bishop
and it's also limiting the c8 bishop as
you cannot easily play the Depot it
would give up material to play the pawn
but this is exactly what who you funded
it's not the only move to in this in
this position but it's an interesting
one takes and Bishop f5 winning this
temple shows it shows it so she's
getting out the bishop and here after
Queenie to she castled so really
focusing on quick development and
getting those Bishop activated yeah that
that's really okay long castle it's yeah
if white takes only seven black is
recapturing and now you have a serious
problem you cannot castle anymore yeah
the queen is on d8 preventing you from
castling and blacks development is
fantastic yeah this is not really a nice
situation to be in if what does
something like that had a pretty obvious
looking move and night ed 5 and look at
this routine is coming yeah this is
really terrible for white so he had to
cancel long instead she took rook takes
Queen c8 yeah and this is I mean it's
probably difficult to grasp her quickly
and you would have to look at it and
more detailed black really has decent
compensation for other porn yeah those
two pieces are not playing why does a
little bit unharmonious and blacks
bishops especially I'm very strong f5
and g7 and after a couple of moves that
that make a fairly standard impression
white comes up with the move
for and this could have been punished
really severely and she played the first
moves right and takes takes rookie for
it looks weird to take on c3 with the
bishop but it's just good due to
concrete lines the rookie is attacking a
form and it's a taking fo Wow it doesn't
look good we should be three was played
and that's the best move relatively
speaking and now I'm I mean if you look
at it afterwards it looks like totally
trivial but she now could have taken the
route on a 4 and neck has a fantastic
position I mean you have simply you have
equal material and you have this White
King in problems what species he are not
playing while black's pieces are all
playing rook on a aid and the Queen iya
they could be improved but even the
Queen has some role on the C file
potentially oppose the the White King
this is really really bad this position
black just has an attack and would be
very difficult now for y22 to hold this
position just to show you I mean if you
want the computer evaluation minus 3
yeah it's really really bad she didn't
take on a form it looks it looks weird I
know but she played Queen evade if you
look at this move it doesn't it does not
look too bad it has it has points if
white now plays let's say rook back
somewhere then 9 a-4 for example is a
really good move intending the check and
so on the only problem is that well
white has a good move they are not look
t2 awesome rubbish he has this move
Bishop c5 and after that the situation
is not clear at all it really isn't yeah
there is some discover the text by the
rook yeah let's say if like now takes
check this is the problem
Joe she gave us check on age six
probably the best move and we had a
repetition here jack but ultimately she
decided to continue which is totally
fine Black has excellent compensation
for the exchange okay well excellent
this may be a bit much but really good
compensation you can vary counsel to
play this position sorry play this
position is black yeah you have one
point for the exchange right has
terrible structure and weaknesses all
around so it still feels very
comfortable for black however after a
six clean back here now this this
happened they actually repeated repeated
moves by the way what was this queen is
free move why isn't he going to be three
or was this an entry and entry mistake
or something it looks weird that you
would go to a three also what about
Bishop g4 Bishop eva is actually what
the computer points out I did look at
the end that much I thought that was
just I just thought it's a repetition
and that's it but what is this move like
am Bishop defy I don't even understand
the point besides taking of course I'm
just winning another pawn but maybe that
is just the point yeah and maybe rook da
it can be prepared prepared it's very
good very weird way to pronounce it
prepared look the eight immediately
there's Bishop d3 ok so this and if now
I'm looks like Bishop d3 we're going to
take 925 ah well that's very strong I
understand yeah that's very strong so if
Queen a3 really was played but it says
so 2 times then she had a chance there
second second opportunity in this in
this game we had yeah well again this
was this was kind of interesting but I
couldn't really get to the bottom of it
and I probably wouldn't have managed
that even with more time time on my
hands so the next game so this is a draw
by repetition next game is Wesley so
with wide against level aronian let's
see and we have an anti-bullying also
known as the Scotch opening but okay
aronia and it's not playing the Berlin
all the time but he does yeah Wesley so
once something else he wants the Scotch
opening we have this 85 the Mises
variation this is some the principled
way in the Scotch for right now for more
than 20 years since Kasparov unearthed
it in the nineteen ninety world
championship match yeah that's a clear
indication that i'm getting old here
this match doesn't feel so long ago to
be but it is 25 years ago yeah the
Scotch opening Queenie 722 that is a
necessary pair of moves to flee again
because black and really has to hamper
White's development here if he goes 95
immediately this is not a good choice
you get white then gets a quick
castleton and he black always has a
slight problem with his advance porn it
sort of limits him and Queenie 7 is
introducing direct counter play when
white is too slow with this development
92 that's the sideline c4s the main move
rook p8 c4 and 94 funny enough if my
database is correct this is already
virgin territory never has been played
on move 9 not happening
not hop happening often and we see that
they spend some time aronian is playing
quickly but rest is so is spending time
f 4 KS to keep the point have six and
now a very interesting concept by by so
he just takes her a seven Ruby seven and
he drops back to F to the idea said
after the capture which was played
boronia and he's got f5 yeah this is a
really crazy opening and you if you are
a chess teacher like I am it's very
difficult to tell or explain people the
the rationale behind those moves why
displaying the Queen all the time and
he's pushing pawns is not developing
pieces yeah it's very difficult in fact
to explain but one way to put it is that
when he decided to advance this pawn to
d5 he really put him yeah some some
burden on himself he has to make sure
that this Center is somehow yeah this is
this issue has to be resolved and it's
very difficult to do with non technical
means he pretty has to play on this move
by move basis and and go from there the
thing is that after this and f5 white is
in fact in a pretty decent shape but it
does not look very yeah it's not a very
obvious way to play of course Queen f3
intending to play a g3 g4 those kind of
moves Queen f7 g3 went back we should be
to unite at 60 wide is catching up a bit
in development and now he went with g4
yeah that's modern chest for you it
doesn't look very harmonious but g4 has
a concrete area g5 winning lots of space
black also has a pretty weird
configuration here the rooks is funny on
b7 the bishop is without a square so
this is definitely playable d5 you are
putting it in the center this pawn
g5 and exactly here we come to a
critical situation in fact after a fork
we nursery here we come to a critical
situation and the game is in fact
decided right here I'm very curious how
long aronia took for the next move he
played instantly yeah so we had to had
this he made this decision when he
played efore I am clearly yeah well this
is the signon the thing that nine
minutes it took for that and things
after night GF 8 he's just lost after
not yet the game is basically over even
even it takes a while but white is
completely completely winning i will
show you why why shortly the move that
had to be played simply on the rationale
that the other movies losing and the
night is attacked so we have to move it
this move was still okay the problem is
always this move Bishop to age 5 and
after g6 and only move this Bishop g6 it
looks fatal but once you come to this
position you will see that this is not a
clear in any way position at all why it
is an exchange up really it's five
points both sides but is an exchange up
but the situation the hook position is
completely out of balance and whites
king is wide open and g5 might fall it's
quite funny that then an engine is
coming to a 000 evaluation after a while
and but it's um it's it's quite clear
that white is not just an exchange of
this is a position where anything can
happen especially if two humans are
playing and the the thing is when we go
back to the game he really only had this
move the movie played nine to GA it is
also answers by Bishop g5 and now white
is fled out winning the reason is that
after g6 the only move that keeps the
Queen white takes with this pawn and
just Winston look at this track
yeah this is a completely false line
what gets a new queen rook takes and now
we can just count what is a piece up
it's a complete piece up yeah for its
their pond no it's just a piece for
nothing and it wouldn't wouldn't be
totally off to resign this position now
but Aronian continued this is actually I
think not a bad decision because the
position is not that easy for why to
play is still not very well coordinated
at least the pieces that black hairs are
somewhat in play and why this still
somewhat yeah he never ever bothered to
move one of those so it's a it's
understandable that he continues but in
order to keep this video at reasonable
length I can tell you that why it was
probably not playing the absolute best
moves all the time but it was always a
winner you know he keeps collecting
stuff yeah even at one moment we had a
situation where I'm sure check yeah he
was a look up check check yeah there's
an extra roof but black hat had some
play in fact he continued for for ages
check until they get get here and here
it gets relatively easy from a technical
point for my from a technical point of
view after this rook age form of you pin
this pawn and when the last porn is of
the board you will really win with this
quickly without any any [ __ ] so a
winner for Wesley so here against aronia
very nice win however it was all due to
one big slip by aronia and when he here
we can really boil it down to that point
97 would have led to a completely messy
unclear game with really unclear
consequences one night GA just just lost
flat-out lost the game ok so if I'm not
mistaken we have all games but the world
champions
right yeah so weiter check cards the
number one polish player against the
world champion also take note that water
shake is the main second of vision and
nowadays so they yeah it's a little bit
of a small continuation of the World
Championship match if you want yeah what
a Shack plays d 4 is normally a default
player and Carlton and plays d6 so he
sticks to this setup that he played
against giri in round one maybe he's
really serious with this and it wasn't
just a one-off kind of thing c4 by water
check and what is Carson playing now he
plays f5 interesting what he's doing is
he transposase to the Leningrad Dutch
variation hmm in a somewhat somewhat
interesting move order this move order
actually keeps the night back on on g8
and allows for a quick Bishop g7 will
see that this is happening sometimes
this can be a point so that the night
can still be developed to h6 or maybe
not developed at all so quickly yeah
what a check plays an interesting move
now I place the movie before yeah this M
is looking very early but the move
before nowadays is considered to be a
good recipe against the Leningrad touch
can be played in various moves orders
move orders and it is a good idea think
especially here to play it really really
quickly to have some counterpart yeah
for this Bishop on g7 what white is
doing he quickly sets up control over a
5 and this is a good thing that you try
to hinder black from pushing the the
pawn to e5 it's a dream scenario for
every Leningrad Dutch play 1e5 and
effort is palmed or note that this
before move is really not comparable to
other quick be4 pushes as black as
committed to a fan cheto so
that's not the same thing as a cold ski
hoping the run it you rang a tang yeah
em council now played the most a five
okay a5 b5 played and now a 4 plate um
this is I mean we are talking about the
position here that basically is unknown
yeah this is actually really great yeah
after move five or six we are they are
just playing chess for once yeah not
just reputa stuff and it's interesting
now this a phone booth and I'm kind of
divided about it this is not an uncommon
motif in this type of position but very
often what what black is doing is I can
show you what what he is getting it why
does not playing III interesting
decision is not fianchetto anymore I
like the idea I can show you what black
is after with this with this April move
if we put all this out Quincy to 2793
and now exactly black plays a three this
is the idea you want to disturb white
with this development however the
questionable thing is is it any good it
takes time you push the apron with like
a 5a for a three yeah and at the end
this pawn is vulnerable in a way to look
be one rook be three and in the game
well this was playing a group b 197
droopy one and in this cell in this
position you see that you have a hard
time to keep the pawn and really once
this poem drops where is the brilliant
compensation for black yeah I understand
that you can play e5 at 11 point but
well if I've alone is not leading to a
quick made or anything causal plays it
in an interesting way he plays the most
knight to e form yeah just putting the
night in the center of the board
after the capture here white a shake had
to be very careful he absolutely should
not take only for this was a poisoned
pawn he played 92 which is much better
if it takes there is this funny
untechnical trick yeah based on this
idea that if white takes them and the
rook drops 92s is much much better
Knight f6 Andrew p3 going after the pot
if white takes only for you have the
same ideas before but rook b3 this is
the problem all along if you push the
apron or way to a 3 it will get lost
what cards and gets for the pawn is he
gets some pieces near White's King we
see that Bishop f5 rube tix and h5 but
to be perfectly honest this looks like
going for swindling chances it doesn't
feel like black should have enough for a
pawn really it sort of is born out of
necessity and you had to had to do this
after you somehow lost this pawn in the
process on a three so when this wasn't
really a great opening result for the
world champion maybe this push of the a
porn really was wrong I don't think he
was worse before I mean this this looks
fairly normal it moved like Knight f6 no
or anything yeah let's come to that it's
not like wide as winning straight very
easily or anything but it's definitely
not a position that he would ever want
to have on the board again with black so
Luke takes rook takes was played and now
the move a 3 yeah putting this pawn out
of harm's way that the queen is not
needed to protect it I think this is all
ok now aged for clear black has to do
something you cannot just sit around an
interesting decision now for white and
and the decision that is very very
difficult i feel i mean let's say if i
would be in white shoes and i would be
pretty confident that i'm clearly better
here but i would really think very hard
do I want to allow age 34 black what do
I want to play h3 myself an interesting
an interesting comparison to make if you
go h3 an issue can be that of course
there are possible sacrifices there like
Quincy 8 and then what taking on a tree
on the other hand if this sacrifice is
not coming it's not quite clear what
what blacks ideas very difficult to to
get to get anything against the king m
he played this and went for this
position and here you always feel like
whenever queen g two hits well that's it
yeah but very difficult to really get
the Queen near the king so I'm undecided
maybe both both setups of about equal
value Quincy eight angling for that you
want to get rid of the light squared
bishops to better infiltrate on those
squares look if one yeah a 4 immediately
also was possible looking one of them
it's not really I mean it has some
points we will see later but a for as
possible I think here here the computer
points out the move Knight to age seven
which is of course totally normal in
this in this position and cards and
plays it one move later but he loses a
bit of time maybe night age 7
immediately was more interesting there
are some really remarkable lines where
black is really getting some
compensation and subscribe interesting
if we look at this for example is why
it's really tries to promote the pawn
yeah very logical sequence and really
black gets some attack going yeah yeah
this is this a supposed a possibility
just putting much much pressure on f2
and there are even other ideas now like
for example yeah look I made is a real
problem but I think why do I probably
has to play the F pony I mean something
like this can I don't know they're
threatening maybe even to take on age
two check check check check yeah I mean
this wasn't the best possible way for
white to play but yeah you get the idea
there is some attack 987 was probably
the best possible way to set problems
the way it was in the game it is very
similar but in the process with rupee
aid and stuff Carlton has somehow lost
move so that Queen to d1 was able here
to cover the g four square so that
Bishop g4 it's not even coming yeah and
here he played the Moose c5 and that is
good ya doing something with the bishop
now why to shake played rook to be 6
yeah maybe that wasn't the best move but
it's it's obviously a very complicated
position and here cousin I think still
if he if he continues with a waiting
move the computer suggest is actually
King age 7 yeah which is in a way a move
that passes the passes white the right
to move but it also does some good
things that covers g6 it gets out of
possible checks on this diagonal or
whatever the king is a little bit better
there in fact White has some really nice
opportunities now to get get himself
into trouble I was really surprised
let's say a five normal looking move it
takes it takes you three this is a big
big point if white takes Queen e6 and
believe it or not black wins
yeah this is all of a sudden completely
turning this is almost a major when it
comes and you cannot really protect it
like that really really problematic so
King edge 705 takes what about Bishop
takes takes and takes and this is a yeah
well a five is not the move against King
edge seven but it is not so easy for why
to play this position you know the
computer is suggesting very after King
edge seven it's a debt suggesting rather
non-intuitive moves like night to be one
I mean I don't really think that a human
players going for that kind of move and
really struggling with the idea I mean
maybe you're intending to to do this and
after Bishop takes yeah okay what you do
is when III comes at some point you can
actually do this the night is not
attacked on the two that's maybe the
point but not be one I mean no it's not
going to be played King age seven was
still putting up a big fight but what
what Carson is doing now he played queen
to d6 at first sight to be honest it
looks totally ridiculous because G for
poops and pees lost it's not that easy
this was played and white is winning
after that um at least that the position
is winning he definitely didn't overlook
the G form what he did is he must have
made some calculation error in what is
coming now he took on d4 recaptures yeah
note that is why does that it was
possible maybe actually G Teague's yeah
it's leading to the same position
actually and then the game he took their
and the bishop is still trapped he took
now on f5 yeah he must have
miscalculated somewhere around here
black is really a complete piece down
and I'm not quite sure what what is what
his miscalculation was as mentioned i
didn't see a press conference or
anything and yeah night everyone that's
a good move white it seems can also go
for that but this is the kind of
position where the computer is saying
while alive I'm winning easily no
problem whatsoever but a human player
will be will still be very sketchy and
like the King here just this and made
and well yeah it's not easy probably to
coordinate for for white um even if the
computer says it's a totally easy win
but believe me for human it's not easy I
think what water shake did is fine he
played night f1 chat can't went for this
position when he's a complete piece up
that's not even like some pawns who
black and he just has to be precise and
not bungle it up yeah he's coordinating
is giving away the airport but he wants
to coordinate his position note that
they were in time Travis oh yeah very
nice move by the way now Queen f4 this
was the move move 40 but my voice check
very nice move yeah putting the Queen on
pre but the capture him Jack leads to a
green trade which is of course very
welcome for what yeah so cars could not
take a sorry he could take he actually
did take me because there's no other
move where do you put the Queen yeah
sorry sorry this was a brain slip yeah
he did take there is there is no other
move yeah I mean you you can go here it
check that's not helping ya can't it was
actually it happened that the queens
were traded he continued a little bit at
first I thought well this is kind of
kind of cheeky to play on with with the
piece down but I admit that there is
some some point to it black as a pawn
and those two points they are so
vulnerable so it is it is not not stupid
to try to continue
especially with the reduced pawn count
white only a three pawns if he gives
away one point somehow it would be very
tricky but what a shake didn't do
anything stupid he just can continued
with good simple just keeps everything
together everything's protected I am and
now ultimately mm-hmm he got to this to
this point where he will pick up the
edge reborn so Magnus Carlsen resigned
this game yeah not a good tournament so
far for the world champion he played two
drawers and lost this game now and the
two drawers weren't especially inspiring
than say well it's well nothing special
net safe and well this was some really
not a great game to be perfectly frank
he played this interesting opening and I
like that he is doing those things
experimenting a bit doing some other
openings that he did before well it's it
should be really the case that there
should be more experimentation out of
outside of those world championship
matches trying out interesting new ideas
um but it would invariably happen that
you yeah for fall on your face once in a
while if you do interesting new things
here it feels like this a pawn push
wasn't that great but yeah I'm kind of
cautious them but it felt to me that
when you push the pawn all the way here
it wins sometime okay yeah that's all
nice but this is ultimately upon sec
yeah this pawn is just dropping and I
don't really see that you have any great
compensation for that as why it has a
very solid position so maybe this a five
then a4a three was a mistimed mistimed
plan he definitely had some chances
afterwards but there was nothing like
Leah cut he never had a think for
compensation for the pawn but maybe if
you analyze
in more detail you will find something
but my my hunch is my my gut feeling is
that wyd really was upon her and with
precise play should should get out of
this and well this was a good game by
what to check here and he's he had a
really interesting tournament so far
think about it he could have won against
West Des so with black really up and
down struggle and today this game really
interesting so I hope you enjoyed the
coverage it is a long video but this was
just so much content I think you could
easily do 30 40 minutes per game of one
over for some of those so this is a good
thing about this tournament the many
games play and very often they're
interesting yeah I hope you enjoyed this
thanks for watching